back to the scandals or if you will if
you if you if you watch television or
you go on the internet if you read the
newspapers you know when I say that you
start shouting or crying or whatever and
says you know it's impossible that this
is happening in this western free
prosperous society well I think in a way
what's perhaps been revealed recently by
the collapse of the mortal the
neoliberal model the collapse the wall
street the thing that was being
signified that stands for a much bigger
catastrophe in a way it's based also on
a kind of delusional kind of thinking
that we've all been caught up in it's
not just the one can't divide us and
them in a way there was a kind of logic
that drew everyone into it that has
perhaps now been exposed in its
delusional aspects which of course the
media also often play into in terms of
the world that where that represents the
crime numbers but that's one schedule
will scandal be we definitely have to
address aurori easter any skin scandal
you can point out it's real scandal that
this is happening in our society very
interesting one over the last ten years
which fascinates me for an advertising
background is that in a sense what
you've got to be really afraid of is
there's vessels of persuasion which
aren't ostensibly persuasive advertising
and propaganda people understand there's
an ulterior motive and they have a
certain resistance to them or at least a
certain cynicism towards them there's a
very peculiar assumption pervaded the
entire western world I mean it's worth
remembering that the banks were totally
responsible lenders but they also had
completely irresponsible borrowers on
the other side I don't know if you can
actually put the blaming entirely
squarely in one place or the other it
was very peculiar narrative which
pervaded all news media which is that
property wasn't a form of consumption it
was massive and the rising property
prices was portrayed as universally good
news on the news that always struck me
as strange no one actually portrays a
rise in petrol prices is great news to
those people who have half a tank full
of petrol in their tank and for whom
their car has suddenly become slightly
more valuable we see it as a cost of
living and there was something very
peculiar there if you looked at sort of
you know endless programs that suggested
the highest end of may
and was to install decking outside his
house and to improve his own home and
what was peculiar about that is it
wasn't the point of view it just became
a universal assumption and that's when
these ideas seem to be actually most
dangerous so but I mean it is worth it
is worth making that point that we
talked about irresponsible lending and
we're absolutely right to producer and
we absolutely right to criticize a
neoclassical economic model which is a
psychologically blonde blind model of
human action which did quite a lot of
harm but there were peculiar behaviors
in other places as well Roger so far
above Daniel and where we are talking
about the scandal of a kind of economic
model although other schedules scandals
or is it what what would you said this
is the real esate leaf and I mean what's
what yes I think the I guess on my view
is not very fashionable I think that the
real scandal of Western civilization
today is atheism and I know that some
people might say well they are more
power to scandal in that case just as I
think the real scandal of the Middle
East today is a ISM of an irrational
kind and I've always hoped that we could
hold on to our inherited sense of the
sacred without going over the top as our
Muslim friends do and it seemed to me
for a while in my youth that this could
even be achieved but I recognize that it
hasn't been achieved and all these
things that have just been said by Rory
and Daniel the growth of if you like of
contagious irresponsibility not only in
economics between in personal life and
social life all this in my view proceeds
from that fundamental loss of the sense
that some things are sacred good we'll
get back to that as well Atkinson now
the vert has always been a dangerous
place and remained the dangerous place
oil via scandals in the world and their
standards today as well but what is a
scandal what is not is also
determined by our own perception we're
avicii something as a scandal and in
this respect I would say that our word
is not that bad because for us for
example genocide is a scandal mass /
that is a scandal for home arrows or 40
p africanos devil no scandal obviously
if you conquer the land yet to destroy
every right to me murder that was fine
that was that was Harry is not scandal
so I think the if he include in the
problems of the scandal certain things
which affordable did not consider
scandals I don't believe in progress but
it is it is partially a kind of progress
in comparison to the 20th century which
was in my mind the greatest scandal of
modernity with all these totalitarian
societies with all these millions and
millions of corpses in Europe in
comparison with this dictatorship with
this mass murder we are not living at
the present moment the scandalous world
although there are many scandals in
desert Allen in respect of necklace
moved if I may say so from communism in
your in your youth when you were a
student of lukács to somebody who is you
no longer consider yourself a communist
to you of course of course not of course
when at the time and I considered myself
as a communist I believe the real Paris
manuscripts of Karl Marx that is the
unity between cat invasion and
individual person which is a total
utopian maybe not just an unrealizable
but also in my present you and desirable
but I believed in this but never
believed in real existing socialism
that's on a totally different version
never and I never used the term
marxism-leninism as well as much as what
novel honest because Lenny discovered
learning invented the totalitarian party
everyone imitated him inventor totally
impart a so I would not
Alma never did not call myself Marxist
Lenny but Marxist yes because i had my
own marks these marks very utopian like
your marks yeah it was very tough Ian it
was beautiful idea and conception which
I still believe a wonderful dream but I
don't think it has political reality um
Alan listen and and one of the books you
publish the Communist hypothesis were
you argue that communism is still a good
idea and from that perspective what do
you see as the big scandals of the
society you live in I think the most
important sir scandal in the world today
but not only two day of the beginning of
history in fact that we definitely know
that practically all man and woman is a
world are able of doing something of
create something of sinking something
and this ability is practically he used
to know nothing for hate majority of
human beings today it was a question of
layoffs poverty or vocation and so on so
more vertical question which is at the
humanity is very distant from its Potter
possibility of creation and of life and
of existence and within the contemporary
capitalism we can clearly see that
millions millions of people are from the
point of view of capitalism itself no
useful at all they are practically
nothing
in fact and so it is calm down the
scandal is when millions of people are
considered practically are not seen not
only in their existence but in the
capacity in the possibilities so I think
la like marks in some sense that you are
now to in a historic sequence of
humanity and we must begin the history
of mankind really and communism was only
for Mac the name of this possess the
name of this possibility the name of the
two beginning of history after many
centuries of destruction struggle
cluster girl everything and so on and
for him capitalism was just a form just
before the possibility of a new
beginning and I think we must recognize
the truth of this ID because we can
observe that so capitalist which is
today adds a scale of the planet cannot
be the construction of a future